senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
vows to bring a vote to the floor
some republican commentators waiver and
the doj declares several major cities
anarchic jurisdictions i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let others track
what you do keep yourself safe at
expressvpn.com
ben alrighty we're gonna get to all of
the news of the day and plenty there is
of it but first let us talk about the
fact that if you are a responsible human
being you do need to get life insurance
right you're a person with children a
family if god forbid something should
happen to you yeah they're gonna be sad
but they're gonna be even more sad when
they find out about the pills they're
attached to your funeral
and also all the bills that will not be
able to be paid because you will no
longer be there to pay them
this is why any responsible person with
dependents should have
life insurance well the good news is
it's still easy to shop for life
insurance right now
if you've got loved ones depending on
your income you should get some right
now you could say fifteen hundred
hundred dollars or more a year
by using policy genius to compare life
insurance policies when you're shopping
for a policy that could last for a
decade or more those savings really do
start to add up policy genius it's an
insurance marketplace
built and backed by a team of industry
experts here's how it works step
one head on over to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need and compare quotes
from top insurers to find your best
price step two
you apply for the lowest possible price
in step three policy genius does all the
rest
they have great service they've got
policies that even allow eligible
customers to skip the in-person medical
exam which is a pain
in the bud so that's fantastic that they
can solve that for you if you need life
insurance head on over to
policygenius.com right now to get
started
you could say 1500 or more a year by
comparing quotes on their marketplace
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it is nice and important
to get it right okay so mr mcconnell
yesterday
he suggested that the time has come
they're going to act
they're not going to wait on it he have
a speech on the floor of the senate
talking
about this president trump himself
suggested that he want to vote before
the election here was president trump
yesterday
saying that he wants this thing to move
forward he wants it to move forward fast
this makes sense because here is the
problem
if you don't get a vote before the
election and mitch mcconnell has
declared that an election
effectively is a referendum on a
question as to who will appoint
the next justice of the supreme court
let's say that november 3rd trump loses
and the republicans lose the senate
going to be very difficult to make the
case that the american people
desperately wanted republicans to fill
that seat so instead you do it right now
before the election that's the logic
here here is president trump talking
well i'd much rather have a vote before
the election
because there's a lot of work to be done
and i'd much rather have it we have
plenty of time to do it
i mean there's really a lot of time so
let's say i make the announcement on
saturday there's
a great deal of time before the election
that'll be up to mitch in the senate
but i'd certainly much rather have to
vote i think it sends a good signal
and it's uh solidarity and lots of other
things
okay so that obviously is the correct
political attack for the president to
take he should not be waiting on this
he should be pushing ahead he's supposed
to announce his pick friday
or saturday and this is one thing that
trump is very good at the rose ceremony
will be beautiful
now you remember that he did this with
brett kavanaugh who will he unleash from
behind the store
open the door it's brett kavanaugh come
on down and receive
your hearing from democrats who will
call you a rapist congratulations
sir okay so we'll get that whole show
mitch mcconnell the senate
majority leader who is absolutely
ruthless let's just point out that mitch
mcconnell is one
cold dude cocaine mitch is a hardcore
operator
he's not going to bring a vote to the
floor unless he knows that he is going
to get the vote
here was mitch mcconnell saying we are
going to act and anybody who says that
we shouldn't
act that those people are very very
silly
no senate has failed to confirm a
nominee in the circumstances
that face us right now
the historical precedent is
overwhelmingly and it runs
in one direction if our democratic
colleagues want to claim they are
outraged
they can only be outraged at the plain
facts
of american history okay well fact check
drew
meanwhile he does have the votes okay so
mitt romney has released a statement
announcing that he is going to
vote in favor of the nominee he is
certainly going to
cure the nominee so that means that he's
bad again so for a second there he was
good now he's bad again that's the way
that it works with mitt romney when he
does the bidding of the left then he
gets the strange
new respect but the minute that he no
longer does the bidding of the left then
he's
as bad as he ever was a racist who wants
to put black people back in chains as
joe biden
suggested that he was back in 2012 he
put forward a statement basically saying
listen
precedent and the constitution are
pretty clear about this not only does
the senate have the authority to go
ahead
with this nomination but when the party
in power
is holding both the presidency and the
senate there is literally no reason for
them not to go ahead
with all of this so mitt romney bad
again meanwhile corey gardner in
colorado and chuck grassley both
stepped up and said that they are going
to move ahead with this as well
there's some questions about grassley
because earlier this year grassley had
suggested that maybe he wouldn't vote
in favor of any nominee brought up this
year but he has reversed himself now and
he was basically like yeah
whatever which is listen all of this is
kabuki theater
if democrats were in charge of the
senate this nominee would not get a vote
right we all know this and if the
democrat if the democrats
had elected hillary clinton and
republicans were in charge of the senate
she wouldn't get a vote either okay this
is just pure power politics everybody
knows this
and this is a pure simple result of the
fact that democrats politicize the court
that's what happened here they shifted
the definition of what it meant to be a
supreme court justice from a person who
interprets the text of the constitution
to a person who acts as a super
legislature giving democrats
all the things they could possibly want
in a second i want to talk about
why it feels like the country is
breaking down over supreme court justice
why is it so important what the
institutions of the country are because
there is a real reason a deep
philosophical reason why we are now
seeing the country basically crack up
over what is a normal constitutional
process but grassley said
once the hearings are underway it's my
responsibility to evaluate the nominee
on the merits just as as i always have
the constitution gives the senate that
authority the american people's voices
in the most recent election could not be
clearer meanwhile cory gardner who is
trailing
john hickenlooper in colorado despite
all sorts of legal questions surrounding
hickenlooper he says i have and we'll
continue to support judicial nominees
we'll protect our constitution and not
legislate from the bench and uphold the
law
should a qualified nominee who meets
this criteria be put forward
i will vote to confirm and again mitt
romney has also announced that he is
going to go forward with the vote as
well so this thing is basically a done
deal
lindsey graham was asked about this and
um and people
got very angry at him because lindsey
graham
of course was a big advocate in 2016 of
not bringing up merrick garland
for vote he said dear senators feinstein
lehigh durbin white house club
charcoon's blumenthal hirono booker and
harris like millions of americans i was
shocked and saddened to hear of justice
ginsburg's death justice ginsburg served
honorably on the federal bench was a
trailblazer for women in
law she will be missed when the american
people elected a republican senate
majority in 2014 americans did so
because we committed to checking and
balancing the end of president obama's
lame duck presidency
we did so we followed the precedent that
the senate has followed for 140 years
since the 1880s no senate has confirmed
an opposite party president's supreme
court nominee during an election year
because our senate majority committed to
confirming president trump's excellent
judicial nominees
the american people expanded the
republican majority in 2018.
we should honor that mandate also unlike
in 2016 president trump is currently
standing for re-election
the people will have a say in his
choices lastly and this is a key point
after the treatment of justice kavanaugh
i now have a very different view of the
judicial confirmation process
compare the treatment of robert bork
clarence thomas samuel alito and brett
kavanaugh
to the treatment of sonia sotomayor and
elegant
and elena kagan this is this is right
lindsey graham 2.0 was basically
launched
by the fact that the democrats went
after brett kavanaugh and called them a
rapist
so lindsey graham says my entire
perspective changed
after brett kavanaugh and he is correct
about this
all the precedents with regard to
judicial nominees were broken and they
were broken because the democrats have a
very different view of what the court
ought to be now this has not stopped the
democrats
from screaming to high heaven that
somehow this is a violation of principle
we'll get to democrats screaming
to the heavens in just one second first
let's talk about
something a risk that you may not be
taking into account in your daily life
well you know we think a lot right now
about covet 19 but
you could theoretically lose your home
because of cove 19. i don't mean because
of foreclosure
the fbi is reporting that cyber crime is
up 75
since coronavirus hit and the cyber
crime that we really need to worry about
is home title theft the legal documents
to our homes are now kept online
which is sometimes not a great idea
cyber thieves foreign and domestic know
this
if you don't protect your home's title
at home title lock.com
here's what could happen thieves could
forge your name on a quick claim deed
and then they can make out that they've
sold your home then they slap
a slap a fake notary seal on it and
refile is the new owner
of your house and then they can take out
loans against your house and you can
suddenly find yourself
in serious debt the bank does not
protect you neither does your insurance
or those common identity theft guys
you're not gonna know until late payment
notices
start showing up for loans you never
took out in the first place well good
news is home title lock puts a virtual
barrier around
your home title the instant they detect
tampering they will shut it down
you know your home may be your most
valuable asset but if you're not
protecting it you're doing something
wrong so head on over to
hometitlelock.com
register your address to see if you are
already a victim then use code shapiro
for 30 free days of protection that is
code shapiro
at home title lock dot com again that is
home title lock dot com go check them
out right now
home title lock.com and use code shapiro
for 30 days of free
production okay so the senate minority
is of course screaming and moaning about
all of this
chuck schumer says it's the
inconsistency that makes you absolutely
crazy it's so inconsistent i mean this
is
this is inconsistent says chuck schumer
the same man who in 2016 was declaring
openly
that merrick garland should absolutely
have a vote even though the democrats
did not control the senate
now he's like we should not have a vote
it's it's
absurd okay here's chuck schumer again
political principle means
nothing in the american senate which is
you know kind of normal here he is
leader mcconnell and chairman graham
have made a mockery
of their previous position they seem
ready to show the word
world their word is simply no good it's
enough
to make your head explode and then to
hear
leader mcconnell up on the floor trying
to defend this
pathetic pathetic chuck schumer so he's
so disappointed in you
mitch mcconnell mitch mcconnell's
sitting there with that tiny little grin
creasing that turtley face he didn't
care here's chuck schumer saying
every modicum of decency and honor
demands that you can fill a seat even
though you have the presidency and a
senate majority here's chuck schumer who
undoubtedly if he had a senate majority
right now
would block this nominee
the right to join a union marry who you
love freely exercise your right to vote
the right of a parent with a child who
has cancer not to watch helpless
as their son or daughter suffers without
proper health care
if you care about these things in the
kind of country we live in
this election and this vacancy mean
everything and by all rights
by every modicum of decency and honor
leader mcconnell and the republican
senator majority
have no right to fill it no right
um they have every right and not only do
they have every right you know who um
you know who used to say that
that would be like every one of these
democrats here's an rnc ad they cut
yesterday
just compendiums of democrats talking
about how merrick garland should be
confirmed even though they did not have
a senate majority of the time the
democrats
instead of just saying the blanket rule
is no matter who you are
no matter what your qualifications
because you are sent by this
president we will create a unique rule
for you
and refuse to entertain you one of the
most important
consequences of who is president united
states assistance on the united states
supreme court
if you want to stop extremism in your
party
you can start by showing the american
people that you respect
the president of the united states we
don't have to listen to these hypocrites
okay here's the bottom line policy
politics makes for hypocrites
and nobody tends to care because your
own base tends to forgive you hypocrisy
but there is something more important
here and that is when you hear chuck
schumer talk about the supreme court he
says
your right to gay marriage your right to
vote your right to health care
all these rights are on the line on this
supreme court pick
understand that what he is really
reflecting is a deeper democratic
sentiment about the role of the supreme
court
in american life namely republicans
generally view the supreme court's job
as reading the constitution and
providing an institutional barrier to
violations of your rights
there's a law the legislature passes it
it violates the first amendment the
supreme court strikes it down
for democrats the legislature is merely
one component
of what government should do meaning
that the supreme court should actually
give them things they could not get
legislatively and
or greenlight things that are blatantly
unconstitutional
for the democrats all institutions of
american government are institutions of
power and to understand
why that is you have to understand
there's a grave philosophical difference
in american life
between what i've called in my book how
to destroy america in three easy steps
the unionists
and this integrationists the unionist
vision of american philosophy is very
simple it's embedded in the declaration
of independence you have certain
inalienable rights granted to you
by god or by nature these inalienable
rights pre-exist government these are
rights to life
liberty and property government was
instituted in order to protect those
rights
okay that is the philosophy of the
constitution of the declaration of
independence and that's the philosophy
of the constitution of the united states
abraham lincoln
called the constitution the silver frame
around the golden apple of that
philosophy so again that philosophy is a
philosophy
of limited government instituted in
order to protect pre-existing rights
the constitution is specifically
designed to protect those pre-existing
rights because what you need
this is the philosophy of the federalist
papers throughout particularly in
federalist 51 by james madison
the basic philosophy is that you need a
government that is powerful enough
to ensure that people's rights can be
protected but not powerful enough to
invade your rights
that's a very delicate balance so how do
you achieve that how do you ensure
that those rights that pre-exist
government are not violated by the
government itself but are protected by a
government that is powerful enough to
protect those rights
on the one hand the founders were trying
to balance the weakness of the articles
of confederation which is the
proto-constitution right the articles of
confederation were the earliest
governing documents of the united states
the problem was they were not sufficient
to actually maintain
order in the united states there were
armed rebellions in the united states
that broke out during the articles of
confederation it turns out
that the federal government did not have
enough power to pay back national debts
it did not have a power to raise an army
it couldn't really fight in any
plausible fashion and so
congress people from all over the united
states came together
in the constitutional convention
originally their idea was that they were
going to
tinker with the articles of
confederation they ended up replacing it
wholesale
the goal of the new constitution again
was to have a government
that was powerful enough if need be in
emergency circumstances to act but not
powerful enough to invade your rights
and so the founders came up with
basically a three-pronged institutional
approach
to creating this government prong number
one enumerated powers
the government only has certain powers
that are enumerated
and listed so the legislature has the
power to legislate on specific
issues having to do with the federal
government and and those issues are
quite limited in scope right the full
list is things like making sure
that mail is delivered they can do that
right they can create they can they
don't have to they can create post
offices
they have the power to levy certain
taxes against the states
there are certain things that are
encompassed in the constitution
and they are named right they are
enumerated powers there was not a
blanket grant of power to the federal
government in the constitution so number
one enumerated powers
but the founders didn't just rely on
enumerated powers or on a bill of rights
they said okay well those are parchment
barriers we need
institutional checks and balances this
is why we have a
two pro a two chambered legislature we
have a house of representatives that is
done by population and then to ensure
that the
big states don't overrule the small
states we have a senate that is supposed
to balance it out where montana has the
same number of votes as california
the idea here is that the checks and
balances will require essentially a
broad scale agreement on a particular
issue in order for anything to happen
and this will protect against violation
of small states rights for example
and then we'll balance that legislature
with an executive we won't have a
unitary executive capable of doing
anything
we won't have a cabinet government like
they have in great britain for example
instead there will be very limited
powers in the executive branch
those very very limited powers in the
executive branch include a veto against
legislative action
but the legislature controls the purse
strings so they can defund the executive
anytime they damn well please and then
there will be a judicial branch and the
role of the judicial branch as alexander
hamilton put it was to be
the least dangerous branch not the most
dangerous branch the least
but that he says the judicial branch
does not have the power
to even effectuate its own judgments so
there is a great argument in american
constitutional law
over whether the judiciary in the united
states the federal judiciary has
judicial supremacy
or simply has the same powers as any of
the other branches meaning that they can
rule for themselves but they can't
actually effectuate those rulings it's
fairly clear from both the text of the
constitution
and from the federalist papers and from
all the debates surrounding the
judiciary that the very notion
that everybody would be bound by the
supreme court's determination of the law
and would not have its own independent
ability to assess the nature of
constitutional law is not correct that
basically
it was meant to be a negotiation between
the three branches the judiciary says
this thing is unconstitutional and then
the legislature says well we think it's
not unconstitutional
and the executive then says okay well
it's either constitutional or it's not
constitutional you have this argument
out
and this has happened throughout
american history where the supreme court
will make a decision the executive won't
like it the legislature will fight with
the executive right all of that conflict
is good the gridlock is part of the
system
and the reason for the gridlock again is
that we want to make sure that the
government cannot just willy-nilly
violate people's rights
the third aspect of american
constitutional government is federalism
the idea here is that local government
generally governs best you want a
federal government that is capable
of protecting the rights of individuals
violated by local government this is why
you want a federal government that for
example after the civil war
is involved in reconstruction to make
sure that states are not violating the
rights of black americans one of the
great tragedies
of american history is that the federal
government did not do enough in the
aftermath of the civil war
to effectuate the newly insured rights
of black americans obviously
so you want a federal government that's
powerful enough to protect the rights of
individuals but
states are given most of the power under
the constitution of the united states
this is why you have a 10th amendment
that devolves authority to the states or
to the people respectively
meaning that most of the legislation is
supposed to be done at the state level
so those are the three principles of the
constitution
right one is enumerated powers the
second is checks and balances and the
third is federalism
and all of that is designed in defense
of a philosophy of limited government
based on inalienable rights that
pre-exist the government
now as i'm about to talk about democrats
don't like any of this
democrats see government as us
government is supposed to give us
all the things and that means
institutional obstacles are very bad
when they control the government
democrats don't have a thorough going
theory of institutions
sometimes the institutions are great the
filibuster is great when you're in the
minority
but when you're in the majority the
filibuster is super bad because the
bottom line is
in the pursuit of utopia any institution
that gets in the way is an obstacle
and any institution that helps you is a
club and that is the way
that democrats view american government
and that is why they are now threatening
american institutions
right they are using this as an
opportunity to completely overthrow
the constitutional structure which they
don't like very much and have not liked
for well over 100 years we're going to
get to more of this
in just one second because you have to
understand the underlying conflict in
order to understand
why this is getting so fraught and what
the real danger is going to be
in the end okay we're going to get some
more of this in just one second first if
you're running a business
there's an issue you probably don't
think much about but it can absolutely
come back to bite you directly on the
button i'm talking about hr issues if
you've ever had
an hr issue it is a giant pain in the
butt the bigger your company gets the
more possible
failings you can have in hr many people
don't even have an hr department why
well it's really expensive like an hr
professional
at your company it can cost you like 75
grand a year and if you're a small
company
and you have like 10 employees do you
really want a person who just sits there
all day long doing hr for you at 75
grand to pop probably not but this is
why you could be using bambi
bambi spelled b-a-m-b-e-e was created
specifically for small business
you can get a dedicated hr manager craft
hr policy and maintain your compliance
all for just 99
a month with bambi you can change hr
from your biggest liability to your
biggest strength
your dedicated hr manager is available
by phone email or real-time chat from
onboarding determinations they customize
your policies to fit your business
and help you manage your employees
day-to-day all for just 99 bucks a month
it's month to month there are no hidden
fees you can cancel anytime let bambi
help get your free hr audit today go to
bambi.com
shapiro right now to schedule your free
hr audit that is
slash apparel bambe.com bam to the bee
dot com
shapiro go check them out right now okay
so the democratic party has since the
early 20th century
been at total war with the declaration
of independence philosophy woodrow
wilson would not try about this
he thought the declaration of
independence was hackneyed he thought it
was old he thought the idea of
inalienable rights pre-existing
government was a lie that government was
the only guarantor of your rights and
therefore government had to be as big
and as powerful as humanly possible
in order to effectuate those rights this
has been the philosophy of the
democratic party for well over 100 years
at this point
that means that the only obstacle
sh to to utopia is ability to implement
and that means that all the checks and
balances when democrats are in power
should go away it means that the
constitution of the united states
should become basically a dead letter
this is why they always talk about the
dead constitution as opposed to the
living constitution by living
constitution they mean
whatever we want is what the
constitution says
and this means that the judiciary should
become a tool of democratic policymaking
and this has long been a democratic
talking point is that the institutions
of the united states
ought to be completely overthrown in
pursuit of this sort of utopian scheme
whereby government grants you all of the
rights you could possibly want and all
the entitlements you could possibly want
all you have to do is give up all of
your doubts about government
invading your rights in the first place
which of course completely overthrows
the rationale
of the american revolution this was this
is not hidden okay this is very clear
philosophers on the left progressive
philosophers from woodrow wilson to john
dewey
stated this sort of stuff openly at the
beginning of the 20th century
and then that particular philosophy has
been given new credence and new
credibility
by the rise of so-called critical theory
right this is the
the critical legal studies genre
basically suggests
that the principles of the declaration
of independence were a lie in the first
place
that the the idea of inalienable rights
pre-existing government defended
by that government those ideas were a
lie
now there are two particular forms that
this lie supposedly took
particular form number one is that this
was a class-based lie that was basically
a bunch of rich people who are
attempting to enshrine
in law and via the institutions of the
constitution their own economic
privilege
this argument was first put forth by a
guy named charles beard a historian
who tried to suggest that the real
reason that the founders did the
constitution
and the declaration the way that they
did is because they were hiding their
own economic interests turns out that
was bad history
but it was a really really big idea very
formative in the generation of the
progressive movement
okay and that has been held by people
like howard zinn it's been carried
forward throughout sort of marxist
if you listen to bernie sanders bernie
sanders talks like this that basically
the institutions of the declaration and
the constitution were created
in order to enshrine class privilege
it's a marxist take on the declaration
of independence and the constitution of
the united states
then we have the racially marxist take
on the declaration of independence and
the constitution of the united states
and this is the 1619 project
and their basic idea is also the idea of
ibram kendi
it's the idea of angela davis and
stokely carmichael the basic idea here
is that all of the institutions of the
united states were not really instituted
in order to protect class privilege
they were instituted in order to protect
racial privilege so
the rights of freedom of speech and
right to bear arms and the right to a
free press
all of that was meant to just enshrine
hierarchies that already existed
and to protect white privilege against
people of other races who could take
control of the government and so that
was the real goal here
and you see this in the discussions now
about systemic racism the systems have
to be torn down
because the systems are themselves
repositories of racism
it's not that you can locate racism in
the system itself you can actually look
at the system and see that it's racist
it's that the product of the system
is racist because the intent behind the
system unconscious or conscious
was racist in the first place so with
that in mind
you have to understand that when the
democrats look at institutions of
american government
they see obstacles to what they want to
do and so they have shifted the nature
of what we thought the supreme court was
the supreme court again was supposed to
be the least dangerous branch
interpreting the text of a statute
just as you don't think of the judiciary
as a dangerous branch of government when
it comes to interpreting a contract
the founders never thought of the
judiciary as a dangerous branch of
government they figured they'll
interpret the text of the constitution
the way they would interpret the text of
a contract democrats don't think like
that for them
the constitution of the united states is
merely an obstacle to be overcome or a
tool to be used if you can get enough
justices on the supreme court and you
can stack it with people who agree with
you
and that is why every supreme court
justice becomes a fighting issue for
democrats because they are losing a tool
of power if they lose the supreme court
they are losing what they use in order
to cram down a particular point of view
if they lose the supreme court
they've completely shifted the
definition of what a justice is supposed
to be
right sonia sotomayor is not interested
in interpreting the text of a statute
sonia sotomayor is interested in
promulgating a leftist view of the
universe this is true of ruth bader
ginsburg as well
for all the worship of ruth vader
ginsburg on civil procedure she was
interested in interpreting statutes
on social issues she didn't give one
good damn about the constitution of the
united states
and that was perfectly clear and that's
true of sonia sotomayor
it's been true in many cases of justice
briar it's been true of many of the
supreme court picks by the left which is
why
democratic picks always vote for the
democratic priorities always
invariably whereas republican picks tend
to vary because republicans are like
okay well there are a lot of ways to
read a statute
democrats like there's only one way to
read the statute and that's the way that
agrees with chuck schumer and nancy
pelosi
in just a second we are going to get to
democrats threats to the institutions
because there are predictable effects of
all of this we're going to get to all of
that in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that there
are a lot of new threats online like
every single day there are new threats
online
some of these threats include things
like ransomware where somebody will hack
into your computer and then they will
hold hostage your data essentially until
you pay them
money this is why you need a
forward-looking
anti-virus and this is where pcmatic
comes in it's a next-generation
anti-virus
designed to stop modern threats like
ransomware independent testing from av
tests just named pcmatic a top performer
in the cyber security industry giving it
the best performance award for 2019.
pcmatic's competition is foreign made
often in countries where malware
originates
pcmatic blocks annoying malicious ads
for hassle-free web browsing
makes your computers faster and more
reliable even after years of use
pcmatic will protect windows computers
including xp vista windows 7 8 and 10
windows servers max macbooks and android
phones and tablets
mpcmatic are just 50 bucks for five
devices for one year with a full 30 day
money back
guarantee if you act now pcmatic has
offered my listeners a free month of
security protection with the purchase of
an annual license to access this offer
head on over to pcmatic.com
ben again to get world-class security
that keeps your computer running
great go to pcmatic.com ben you keep all
your data which is
like a lot of your life on your computer
make sure it's protected pcmatic.com
ben okay so with all of this in mind
democrats look at the supreme court pick
and they see the possibility of breaking
institutions woodrow wilson wanted to
completely overthrow the constitutional
structure by creating an executive
government
millions of people strong in order to
effectuate the wishes of the big man
on top fdr in the 30s wanted to pack the
court to make the court just another
tool in his arsenal
against many constitutional principles
lbj ran roughshod over many principles
of the constitution in terms of private
versus public
in order to effectuate what he wanted
barack obama declared the government is
us because there's a long stand this is
not this is nothing new
it's just that the democrats have now
decided they can come out openly
and basically suggest that it's time to
break all of america's institutions
in pursuit of a pure majoritarianism see
democrats
have believed for a while now really
since the election of barack obama that
they have a majority in the country
and therefore all obstacles should go
away it used to be the democrats
worry deeply about tyranny of the
majority right the founders worried
about tyranny of the majority that is
one of the reasons you have checks and
balances and federalism
what they did not want what they were
afraid of was what they called mob rule
what they meant by mob rule is not mobs
running around burning things what they
meant was
51 percent of the population ruling with
an iron hand over 49 percent of the
population
because at a certain point the 49 are
gonna go you know what we're out we are
not
interested in engaging in this
particular deal
when we are constantly being victimized
by the 51 of the population who violate
our rights
and so the founders were deeply worried
about majoritarian tyranny
now democrats used to worry about this
too because democrats in many areas
were not actually the majority right
they were worried about
they loved the filibuster when george w
bush was president and he had a
democratic
and he had a democratic minority they
still have the filibuster right now even
while declaring it a jim crow relic
twice in the last six months they've
used the filibuster a jim crow relic
according to barack obama in order to
stymie covet relief
and police reform so they're worried
about majoritarian tyranny
when they are in the minority and when
they're in the majority they cannot wait
to effectuate majoritarian tyranny
because they have no institutional
allegiance
to the constitution of the united states
and its structures
and so for them they believe they're in
the majority this by the way undergirds
a lot of their take on 2016.
after 2008 and barack obama wins the
sweeping victory and then 2012
obama governs pretty radically from 2009
to 2012
and democrats figure okay we might be in
trouble here and then
obama wins a fairly broad victory over
mitt romney despite all of that
democrats figured we're never losing
again
we are the true majority and then when
trump won they couldn't handle it
because their forever majority was not
there
and so they pointed to the popular vote
they said okay well we do have a
majority and so you started hearing
rumblings about getting rid of the
electoral college which they had loved
up until that very moment
you started hearing rumblings about
let's reconstitute reconstitute the
united states senate
you heard rumblings about let's pack the
court all this preceded the supreme
court pick
in open debate democrats were talking
about the undemocratic nature of the
american senate they were talking about
the evils of the electoral college they
were talking openly about packing the
court six months ago
before any of this happened right so
when they believe they are in the
majority they are very much in favor
of majoritarian tyranny and they can't
handle the fact that sometimes they're
not in the majority now
everybody should be afraid right left or
center of majoritarian tyranny we've
seen it too many times in american
history
the story of jim crow is a story of
majoritarian tyranny
where 51 of the population is literally
depriving black americans of their
rights under the constitution of the
united states right that is majoritarian
tyranny
american government for all of its
failings was designed to prevent
this sort of stuff okay but because
democrats now believe that they are in
the majority they want majoritarian
tyranny and they want it bad
here is a and so the media who have
allegiance to this idea
they say it's time to wreck all the
institutions the institutions got to go
here is just a mashup of a bunch of
members of the media
encouraging the democrats to break all
the institutions in american life
the only way that we restore fairness
is for congress uh to pass an act
expanding the court
do you say democrats if they get back
the senate in this election in november
should then expand move to expand the
supreme court are you in favor of trying
to expand the
the numbers of justices on the supreme
court like the idea of eliminating the
filibuster should they do that
as you know some democrats are openly
threatening to try to pack
the supreme court with additional
justices would you agree with that
potentially changing the number of
justices on the court changing the
filibuster
changing the number of states in the
union so the media
have been pushing this extremely
extremely high now harder than many of
the democrats
some democrats still have some sort of
institutional allegiance like dianne
feinstein came out yesterday and she
said i don't really want to get rid of
the filibuster i think it's important
she got reamed members of the media were
enraged by the fact that dianne
feinstein who's i believe 80 years old
and senator from california out here
she said she didn't want to get rid of
the filibuster democrats were absolutely
enraged don lemon demonstrating his own
lack of knowledge about anything basic
to the constitution i mean you know
that you're really really dumb about
american politics when chris womo and
chris cuomo an actual block of wood with
fewer than three brain cells to rub
together
is looking at you like dude you don't
know what the hell you're talking about
so here was don lemon
last night suggesting it was time for
the electoral college to be scrapped
via a non-constitutional amendment which
would in fact be required
also suggesting it's time to burn down
all the institutions and chris cuomo was
like
dude what are you talking about when
you're too radical for chris cuomo by
the way
this is a news show according to brian
stelter a reliable source of cnn
here were two of our intellectual
heavyweights this clash of the
mental titans going at it on cnn last
night
we're gonna have to blow up the entire
system and you know what we're gonna
have to do i don't know do you know what
we're gonna yes we
have to do you just gotta honestly from
what your closing argument is
you have to get rid of the electoral
college because the people i don't see
it
because the minority in this country
decides who the judges are and they
decide who the president is
they need a constitutional amendment to
do that and if democrats if joe biden
wins
democrats can stack the courts and they
can do that amendment and they can get
it passed well
you need two thirds to vote in the
congress in three quarters of the state
legislature they may be able to do that
by the way it is not just um don lemon
who doesn't understand how the electoral
college works or how the cons
if he thinks they can simply by
constitutional amendment get the
electoral college abolished good luck
with that seriously good luck
that that is not how that process is
going to end up working reza oslan
meanwhile is tweeting
he he tweeted immediately he's a
commentator for cnn of course
really good guy reza aslan so he he
tweeted out
uh earlier this week that it was time to
burn it all down and he reiterated that
yesterday quote been a few days since i
tweeted that if gop tried to jam
a scotus through before election we
burned the effing thing down and since
the death threats and breitbart
headlines about my tweet have now
stopped let me just say that if gop
tried to
jam scotus through we burn the effing
thing down
but here's the thing democrats are
always in favor of burning the effing
thing down unless they get what they
want
right that is the goal here now what's
crazy about this
is that let's say that they burn the
effing thing down let's say they burn it
down let's say they make all these
institutional changes let's say that
they get rid of the filibuster let's say
they get rid of the electoral college
let's say
that they add states via 51 vote
majority in the senate let's say that
they pack the court
don't you believe that it'll dissolve
the country democrats have to know this
or they don't care or they believe that
their majoritarian tyranny will simply
hold
if you are a state do you think that you
are going to listen to a law made by a
process that you did not approve of at
any stage
that simply adding states willy-nilly
through a simple majority vote in the
senate
and making a permanent democratic
majority on that basis you think the
minority states are just going to stick
around for that
and then when you pass something
unconstitutional in a packed rigged
supreme court green lights it you think
they're just going to sit around for
that the answer of course
is no see for democrats when they say
burn it all down
what they mean is we wish to run this
thing with an iron hand from above
now this is a problem for joe biden as i
mentioned yesterday because joe biden's
entire pitch is
i'm a doddering old man who's not going
to bother you very much and now the
democratic party pitch says we are going
to burn the whole thing down you see how
these two messages are somewhat in
conflict but joe biden does not have the
strength of character
or the strength of mind frankly to
simply say we're not going to do any of
that stuff
see joe biden could still win in a walk
all he would have to say is it is
immoral
for the republicans to try to push
through justice their hypocrites blah
blah blah blah blah right he can do the
same routine that chuck schumer did
but american government is durable
the constitutional system is valuable
and so we're not going to burn anything
down we're just going to win elections
that's all he has to say he can't do it
he can't do it
because the heart and soul of the
democratic party is in favor of burning
things down
if they feel they can effectuate their
power grab by burning things down so he
was asked specifically joe biden was
yesterday
about packing the court he wouldn't rule
it out he wouldn't just say no we're not
going to pack the court
now let's be real about this if you look
at the constituency
of the supreme court right now the
supreme court ages
right now what you are what you are
looking at is
clarence thomas is now 72 years old
stephen breyer is 82. john roberts is 65
alito is 70.
okay so if joe biden were to win the
presidency
there is a not insignificant shot that
he would get to replace
certainly briar that he would also get
to replace clarence thomas who again is
72 years old
and that he might get to replace samuel
alito who will be 74 or 75 by the time
that joe biden leaves office and if he
serves two terms
there is very little doubt that he would
get to replace probably three of those
justices
because that's the way this works gang
okay that is the way that this works
there is turnover at the supreme court
level so he could
just say i'm not going to do any of this
but he won't do that because he's so
afraid of his left wing so should
americans
really gamble that joe biden is going to
stand up to the radicals in his caucus
who wish to burn it all down
i don't see why he would really i'm not
seeing any evidence here is joe biden
wavering on this this is the easiest
answer in the world it's like can you
condemn antifa for burning down cities
just by name it'll be like no
these are easy answers joe biden is not
a bulwark in favor of moderation he is
not
i'm not going to answer that question
because it will shift all the focus
that's what he wants he never wants to
talk about the issue at hand he always
tries to change the subject
let's say i answer that question then
the whole debate's going to be well
widened setter didn't say
biden said he would or wouldn't that's
good
the discussion should be about why he is
moving in a direction that's totally
inconsistent with what the founders
wanted
this is insane it's not inconsistent
with what the founders wanted to appoint
to justice when you have a majority in
the senate and the presidency
the fact that you won't answer the ques
that's not the distraction that's not a
distraction
that is the key question are you willing
to burn it all down and joe biden will
not answer the question
if you wish to have a country that
continues to work the answer always has
to be from all sides
no i am not willing to burn it all down
because if you are willing to burn it
all down we have a fundamental conflict
that cannot be bridged
by some sort of ham-handed deal in a
second we're going to get to some
conservatives people who are friends of
mine
who are calling for some sort of
ham-handed deal i strongly
disagree we'll get to that in just one
second first
this october the daily wire god king is
going to be presenting alongside an
incredibly successful group of business
owners at expert ownership live that's a
virtual conference about leading
through crisis you may have noticed that
covet 19 has really put a damper
on a lot of businesses i can say that
daily wire has been growing and
exploding
and a lot of that is due to the god
king's leadership jeremy boring well
he's going to be speaking at this
conference if you want to learn the
secrets of our growth
go check this thing out at
expertownershiplive.com
ben the conference features a lineup of
speakers like world renowned leadership
author john maxwell the founders of duck
commander and otterbox the benjam
brothers and many others who can relate
to what entrepreneurs and leaders are
going through
right now they'll share stories about
their own businesses and startup
journeys the tough times that come with
any company
and how they were able to come out even
stronger on the other side it's a great
great program
filled with people who know how to run a
business i think there's a lot to learn
the best part if you go to expert
ownership live dot com slash ben right
now
you'll be able to register for only 97
bucks with an opportunity to buy a
second ticket for a friend
half off come on do it for jeremy
otherwise he's gonna be lonely guys go
to expertownershiplive.com
register for only 97 bucks for a limited
time only that's expertownershiplive.com
go check it out right now okay in just a
second we're going to get to
various conservatives who are now
suggesting a deal
and i just don't understand why you
would believe that a deal is a good idea
with people
who refuse to rule out burning down the
system
that's not a deal that's just called
blackmail we'll get to that in one
second first
as part of our daily wire audience there
are a number of ways to take in this
podcast
you could listen on apple podcast
spotify or another podcast app
you could also watch our podcast on
youtube facebook or over at
dailywire.com bottom line
we are making our content available to
you anywhere you want to watch or listen
dailywire members can now enjoy our
shows at apple tv and rocco some members
can enjoy all of the visual elements of
this podcast
and our other shows on your big screen
either live or on demand find the daily
wire on apple tv or roku download today
you do have to be an insider member to
watch live so head on over to
dailywire.com
shapiro and use code watch at checkout
to get 15 off your membership
purchase this deal is not going to last
long act fast if you want live shows on
your big screen plus
the one of a kind highly coveted often
duplicated
often imitated never truly
i don't know whatever leftist your
tumblr go check it out again that's
dailywire.com
shapiro to get 15 off with codewatch and
download the daily wire
on your apple tv and roku today you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show
in the nation
[Music]
so we are now seeing uh a cadre of
conservatives who are getting a little
bit
skimpish is kind of squeamish i would
say about the idea of pushing through a
supreme court justice when you have a
majority in the senate or the presidency
jonah goldberg with whom i'm friends
i like jonah a lot but he's dead wrong
about this he has a piece over at the la
times
saying that republicans and democrats
should make a deal he says i'll confess
there was a time when i would have
considered the question facing
republicans in no brainer
of course they should seize this
opportunity to replace rbg with a
conservative
moving the courts especially the supreme
court right word has been a conservative
load star for generations
it remains one of the last tenets of
pre-trump conservatism that still
largely unites the right
in fairness the conservatives who take
these matters seriously would say the
issue isn't so much moving the court's
right word as it is restoring the courts
to their proper role
they we believe the primary reason these
fights have become so ugly
is the judiciary has taken upon itself
legislative functions it does not have
that's why even pro-choice conservatives
and even pro-choice liberals like
justice ginsburg believe roe versus wade
was
deeply flawed when supreme court
justices do the job of politicians it
shouldn't be a surprise confirmation
battles resemble political campaigns
and of course that is exactly right that
is exactly right
i mean that's the case that i've been
making here but says jonah goldberg
a few republicans could agree to
postpone the process until after the
election
in exchange for a few democrats agreeing
never to vote for a court packing scheme
this would give voters some buy-in for
whatever happens next if no democrats
agree
then their issue is really with the
system and republicans should feel free
to vote for trump's pick even in a lame
duck session
of course if trump wins he gets his pick
anyway and there's no reason he
shouldn't nominate someone now
versions of this idea have been getting
steam among eggheads but there's little
sign it is catching on among senators
well the reason
that it's not catching on is because no
one has any trust in the other side that
they will not burn down the system once
you bring out the threat you're going to
burn down the system
why should we trust you when you say you
are not going to burn down the system
okay the the person who takes a child as
a host the terrorist takes a child as a
hostage
if you say i'm making a deal with you
the deal is don't take the child as a
hostage
the problem is they're the kind of
person who would take a child as a
hostage so why would you make a deal
with them
this is what israel learned when it
negotiated with the palestinian
terrorist authority
and when you do that it turns out you're
negotiating with the kinds of people who
routinely do terrorist things okay if
you were threatening
six months ago to pack the courts
obviously
there's a major moral distinction
between actual terrorists and what the
democrats are doing today
what the democrats are doing today is
hostage taking on a political level that
is incredibly ugly and threatening to
burn down system
which is you know political terrorism is
not the same as like terrorism and
terrorism but
what democrats have been threatening for
years is to wreck every institution of
american government
so why would i believe any promise that
they will in exchange for you doing what
they want
not wreck the government they're the
kinds of people who've already
threatened to direct the government so
they have no credibility when they say
that they're like are you the kind of
person who would threaten to wreck the
government if you didn't get what you
wanted
is that if the answer is yes then
negotiating with you not to wreck the
government seems
simply like exceeding to blackmail
okay but it is not just jonah who's
making this case brett stevens over the
new york times is making this case he
wrote a let an open letter to mitt
romney already said that he's going to
vote in favor
of uh of bringing the nominee forward
brett stevens wrote
an open letter to mitt romney saying
that
maybe there's a deal to be made he he
points out that democrats have been the
great sinners on issues judicial for
generations which is true going all the
way back to
robert bork and clarence thomas and
justice kavanaugh
but he says you know what maybe we
should you know
like make a deal he says i respect the
fact that you're a pragmatic politician
who values the views of your colleagues
and constituents
but as you so eloquently put it in
february when you cast the loan gop vote
to convict president trump in his
impeachment trial
freedom itself is dependent on the
strength and vitality of our national
character
a republican party that lies and
bamboozles voters contributes nothing to
improving
that character so he says it's bad that
republicans suggested that they weren't
going to give merrick garland a vote and
now you need to stand up for principal
and not give
a vote to a republican appointee which
of course is very silly because
the parties were obviously not in the
same position then
that they are now again i like all these
people i know
brett i know jonah i dave i'm very good
friends with david french had a long
conversation with david french
on friday about this specific issue okay
he has a piece in time magazine
suggesting that republicans cut a deal
he he suggests that republicans
basically make a deal with some of the
democrats in order to
back down he says
we know that president trump will put
forward a nominee he's promised to do it
quickly
now a critical mass of the senate faces
a choice at the end of the day do
principles matter at all or is power the
only coin of the realm
after all while much can happen between
now and november 3rd the democrats may
well hold the house narrowly take
control of the senate and win the white
house
at that point they'd have the legal and
constitutional power to not just reverse
conservative control of the court by
amending the law to increase the number
of supreme court seats
they could also permanently alter the
balance of power in the senate by
admitting new states
namely puerto rico and washington dc
republicans would object conservative
americans would protest they'd appeal to
norms and worry about a tyranny of the
majority but if power is all that
matters now
democrats could respond but the same
three words from the start of this piece
elections have consequences so
he says he should that trump should make
the pick the senate should apply the
schumer principle and give
a hearing and then they should delay it
until after the election
okay first of all the comparison between
nominating a judge
and confirming a judge to the supreme
court when you have a majority in the
senate and the presidency
and packing the court which again has
not been done since like 1860
or getting rid of the filibuster or
adding states willy-nilly
there is no norm not to confirm a
justice when a president of your own
party
nominates the justice that is that is
not a norm the fact that that
the republicans articulated this stupid
sort of bizarre broad norm in 2016 was a
mistake for sure but
is that a norm on par with don't break
all the fundamental institutions of the
democracy
the answer of course is no and again if
you are threatening to break those
institutions
why exactly would i trust you not to
break the institutions
the answer is i wouldn't okay meanwhile
there are a couple of
people who are sort of on the on the
short list for president trump
one of course is amy coney barrett
apparently he met with her
yesterday according to fox news fox news
says
that he met with her yesterday at the
white house on monday trump said he had
narrowed his choices down to
five potential nominees while speaking
to reporters he specifically addressed
potentially nominating
barbara lagoa a cuban american who
serves on the 11th u.s circuit court of
appeals
he said i may she's highly thought of
there's a lot of talk about the fact
that she
is a latino woman of i believe cuban
extraction
from florida she's obviously she's been
in favor of uh governor ron desantis
over there who appointed her to the
state high court before she was
put on the federal high court she was
considered
uh she was considered for higher courts
before
here barbara lago's record seems to be
pretty good uh so the the information
that i have about barbara lagoa
seems to be pretty solid which is that
she's ruled on some contentious cases
she was confirmed overwhelmingly by the
senate by the way 80 to 15 including
many many top democrats the aba gave
lagua a unanimous rating of well
qualified prior to the 11th circuit
confirmation
she was involved in an 11th circuit 6-4
decision upholding a florida law
requiring
ex-felons to pay outstanding fines fees
and other costs before being permitted
to vote
because she said okay you actually have
to fulfill all of your obligations
including fines and fees before you
vote democrats of course accused her of
attempting to shut down the right to
vote she's also spoken
at length about originalism during her
confirmation hearings she spoke about
the value of originalism for folks who
don't follow constitutional law
originalism is the very simple concept
that the text of a statute
should be read as it was written when it
was written in other words
you shouldn't write a statute in 1890
and then interpret it using the verbiage
of 2020.
you might say that you shouldn't write a
statute about women and men in the civil
rights act of 1965 and then interpret it
as the women and men
meant transgenderism in 2020. so this
would be barbara lagoa
cracking back against the idea that you
should interpret a statute in any way
other than the original meaning of the
statute here was
barbara lagoa testifying during her 11th
circuit nomination nomination hearing
if we are not bound by what
the constitution means and it's and it
is ever-changing
then we are no different than the
country that my parents fled from which
is cuba
because cuba has a constitution and a
bill of rights and it means nothing
because there is no one to hold it and
to say this is what the definition of
this constitution means if it is
always ever changing the principles that
are were articulated in the constitution
at the time of ratification
have a meaning that meaning is constant
what changes
is uh the application of the meaning to
new things like new technologies in the
fourth amendment context for example
okay so that is an excellent
articulation of the principles of
originalism
the the other possible nominee is of
course amy coney barrett she was talked
about to fill
justice it ended up being justice
kavanaugh's seat i was a big proponent
of amy coney baird i suggested that she
be nominated
instead of justice kavanaugh who i still
have my doubts about in terms of his
jurisprudence we'll see where we end up
coney barrett does not have a huge and
long history on the court
she was nominated to the seventh circuit
just a few years ago
both of these women by the way are quite
young now barbara goes in her early 50s
amy coney barrett is 48.
she's a pro-life roman catholic on a
personal level she clerked for anthony
scalia after she graduated
from law school and she's kind of her
most famous articulation of her
philosophy is in an article for the
notre dame
law review she taught at university of
notre dame called originalism and starry
decisis about justice scalia
and there she was trying to negotiate
the sort of difference between
originalism where you look at the text
of the constitution and bad decisions
how often do you simply
acquiesce to bad decisions that have
been made over the course of american
history because they're so deeply
embedded in the fabric of american law
so for example
there are a lot of legal questions not
moral questions legal questions to be
asked about brown versus board
it's long been an area of serious
contention among legal scholars
so justice scalia said that's so
embedded in the fabric of american life
that you cannot remove it it constitutes
what amy coney barrett said was
super precedent meaning its precedence
so deeply embedded that you can't get
rid of it she explicitly in this notre
dame law review article
excludes roe versus wade as super
president she says it is not super
precedent because it has been a topic
of conversation and controversy ever
since roe vs wade was decided
in 1973. so she uh
she obviously is made in this sort of
scalia mold
uh i'm looking over the records of both
of them today hopefully i'll have some
more details for you tomorrow
on first glance both coney barrett and
barbara lagoa look like very solid
originalist texturalist picks for the
court and then the question becomes the
politics of the situation lagoa
theoretically could win some more
cuban-american votes in florida for
president trump if she were nominated
coney barrett
is a a white catholic theoretically if
she were to be attacked by democrats who
get over their skis in the same way they
went after justice
justice kavanaugh then you could win
some additional votes in wisconsin
michigan pennsylvania
political considerations will be first
and foremost listen if i were just going
to pick a justice
based on who i thought would be a good
justice i just picked ted cruz because i
know exactly what cruz's constitutional
philosophy is
he's pretty consistent with it and he
would actually make a pretty good
justice he's iconoclastic and he's a
good writer
but if you're picking between these two
ladies from what i have seen
both of them look pretty good at this
point those are those are the people who
are at the top of the list barbara lagoa
and amy coney barrett and i'm looking
forward to this week speaking with
proponents
for each uh presumably before president
trump makes a pick
okay meanwhile the doj
in in other news has designated new york
seattle and portland
as what they call anarchic jurisdictions
well what they mean by this
is that the state and local governments
in these cities have allowed
violence to run roughshod over the
cities and the justice department has
said
that we are not going to provide federal
funding or federal help to cities that
basically refuse to enforce the law
according to nbc new york new york city
is one of three places that have
permitted violence and destruction of
property to persist
and have refused to undertake reasonable
measures to counteract criminal
activities
leading to its designation as an
anarchist jurisdiction according to the
doj on monday
the designation does have potential
financial consequences president trump
issued a memo earlier this month
directing the doj to identify
jurisdictions that in its view were not
enforcing the law appropriately
and designated cities could lose their
federal funding new york governor of
course
andrew cuomo of course got very very
angry about all of this he said i
understand the politics when you try and
manipulate and distort government
agencies to play politics which is what
the trump administration has done from
day one
this is more of the same the president
can't supersede the law
and say i'm going to make those funds
basically discretionary funds which is
what he would have to do
if they actually do this we'll challenge
it legally and they will lose once again
trump's september 2nd order gave the
director of omb the office of management
and budget 30 days to issue guidance to
federal agencies on restricting
eligibility for federal grants for the
cities
on the goj list such grants make up a
huge portion of new york city's already
strapped annual budget more than seven
billion dollars in fiscal 2021 alone
or 7.5 percent of the city's projected
total revenue
the doj cited the new york city rising
gun violence the cuts to the nypd budget
and moves by various das not to
prosecute charges
related to protests earlier this summer
portland and seattle were also hit
with the same designation william barr
in a statement the attorney general
he said we cannot allow federal tax
dollars to be wasted when the safety of
the citizenry hangs in the balance
it's my hope the cities identified by
the doj today will reverse course and
become serious about performing the
basic function of government and start
protecting their own citizens now listen
i'm in favor of local rule if you want
to vote for a crappy government that is
going to remove police from your
neighborhoods
by all means go ahead and do it but as a
federal taxpayer i don't see why i
should have to subsidize
your crappy local governance so long as
you're taking i've had a very basic rule
when it comes to accepting federal
funding
if you get in bed with the federal
government do not be surprised when you
get aft
okay and the fact that the the federal
government is now saying
we are not going to we are not going to
subsidize
cities that refuse to enforce their own
laws
frankly i have no problem with it at all
you decided to rely on the federal
government for your budget
that means there are strings attached
hilariously enough a.g letitia james
who is one of the most
mewling awful public servants in america
and she's militarized her office against
political opponents
when she was campaigning she explicitly
said that she was just going to go after
donald trump
she said that she was going to go after
political opponents which is the
opposite of what neg is supposed to do
normally you identify criminal activity
and then based on the identification of
criminal activity you go ahead and you
prosecute the person who committed the
crime
letitia james identified the prospective
criminal
and then decided that she wanted to go
after donald trump
she's a terrible terrible ag
of the state of new york nonetheless
here she was saying it's arbitrary and
capricious to call us antarctic
weird because andrew cuomo said like two
weeks ago that if donald trump wanted to
visit new york city he would need an
army
in order to visit new york city which
sounds kind of anarchic doesn't it
it's important that individuals
understand that this president is doing
nothing
more than saber rattling rattling to his
base
using words and phrases
that unfortunately um are filled with
racial overtones
couched and baked in racial overtones
and appealing to his base
so this is in violation of the
constitution and violation of
anti-commandeering statutes
in violation of the 10th amendment in
violation
of the spending clause because congress
has the power of the purse
it is arbitrary and capricious as you
mentioned
because there are only three cities that
are on this list
okay so maybe they should add more
cities to the list honestly like if
we're cutting federal funding maybe we
should add more cities to the list now
we'll find out in court whether there's
actual whether it's mandatory spending
or discretionary spending
but labeling cities that are badly
governed as not great targets for
federal dollars
on principle i forget the legal legalese
for a second on principle
it's not a bad idea meanwhile ron
desantis in florida has introduced
legislation
to combat violence looting and disorder
this
would add new criminal offenses to the
state law in florida a
prohibition on violence or disorderly
assemblies a prohibition on obstructing
roadways
and including that the law would say a
driver is not liable for injury or death
cost of fleeing for safety from a mob
which good i mean i've been saying for a
while that if you're in a car and you're
on a freeway and a mob surrounds you and
starts pounding
on the top of the car and jumping on top
of the car and then you move the car
that would be on them
here's the rule you jump in front of a
moving vehicle that one's on you
you try and break into someone's car
while they're in the car whatever
happens next that should be
on you he's also put up he's also
pushing for a state prohibition on
destroying or toppling
monuments and a prohibition on
harassment in public accommodations so
in other words
don't gather in front of somebody's
restaurant
and decide that you're gonna rush in and
drink their beer and scream at them
and increasing penalties including
mandatory minimum jail sentences and
offense
enhancements this is good meanwhile this
has been declared racist by a bunch of
people of course
on the left who believe that black lives
matter should basically be able to
engage in any sort of violence activity
they choose and by the way the the
antifa black lives matter movements
have been invading the suburbs nelly
bulls who's been doing increasingly
excellent reporting
believe it or not for the new york times
right she's the the person who
originally
reported in the new york times that
portland was a hell hole now she has a
piece
talking about black lives matter protest
tactics
quote terence moses was watching
protesters against police brutality
march down his quiet residential street
one recent evening
when some in the group of a few hundred
suddenly stopped and started yelling
mr moses was initially not sure what the
protesters were upset about but as he
got closer he saw it his neighbors had
an american flag on display
and one from a peaceful march calling
out the names to all of a sudden bang
how dare you fly the american flag
said mr moses was black and runs a
non-profit group in portland
they said take it down they wouldn't
leave they said they're going to come
back and burn the house down
mr moses and others blocked the
demonstrators and told them to leave
we don't go around terrorizing folks to
try and force them to do something they
don't want to do
said mr moses whose non-profit group
provides support for local homeless
people
i'm a veteran i'm for these liberties
nearly four months after the killing of
george floyd by the minneapolis police
some protesters against police brutality
are taking a more confrontational and
personal approach the marches in
portland
are increasingly moving to residential
and largely white neighborhoods where
demonstrators with bullhorns shout for
people to come out of your house and
into the street and demonstrate their
support
these more aggressive protest tactics
target ordinary people going about their
lives especially
those who decline to demonstrate
allegiance to the cause that includes a
diner in washington who refused to raise
her fist to show support for blm or in
several cities confused at drivers who
happened upon
the protests we don't need allies
anymore said stephen green an investor
and entrepreneur in portland who is
black
we need accomplices and this is the
shift in thinking that has been
happening this is what rhonda sanchez is
trying to fight
that it's not enough for you to post the
black square on your twitter
of course it was never going to be
enough now you're going to be roped into
whatever act of allegiance you require
today and by the way
there is no end to the demands there is
no end to the demands the demands just
continue
one of the leaders of this particular
ideological movement
is ibrahim kennedy kendy he wrote the
book how to be an anti-racist it is a
garbage
trite piece of tyrannical crap it is
unbelievably disgusting
the basic premise of how to be an
anti-racist is that on a top-down level
you should be forced into acquiescence
to anything ibrahim x-kenny personally
approves
in fact he says it's never ending it's
like a religious struggle he says you
can't wake up one day and say i'm out
i'm now an anti-racist
no one ever becomes an anti-racist it's
only something we can start to be
ah that's a religious principle now
anti-racism and that religious principle
means
that ibrahmax kennedy will get to
dictate to you anything that he wants
you to do which is why he has explicitly
called for a department of anti-racism
at the federal level the department of
anti-racism would be given the power to
strike down
when we talk about wrecking american
institutions in favor of majoritarian
tyranny
this is what we're talking about abram
kennedy would like to have a department
that strikes down any
local state or federal law that results
in equality between inequality between
groups which would be every law
because it turns out there is no law
that is guaranteed to provide equality
between groups in result
unless you are going to take all
authority up to the central government
and then devolve
particular benefits to everybody which
is exactly what ibrahim kenzie wants
th this is the this is the crusade when
you combine the institutional
deer election and hatred that democrats
have for the constitution
unfortunately on a broad level a broader
and broader level these days
with the ibramex kenny vision of an
american government that crams down on
everyone his version of language
abram x kennedy is like i'm anti-anti-he
he literally wants to rewrite words
right
he is anti-freedom he says there should
not be a designation of i'm not racist
you're either racist or you're
anti-racist to be anti-racist means you
have to be against the system
he's not trying about this he says this
openly to be anti-racist means
you have to tear down systems of power
and institutions of power and
you have to be forced into being a
quote-unquote accomplice right this is
what you're seeing reflected
in these marches this is supremely
dangerous it tears apart the country the
fact that this is now repeated
in diversity training at corporations
that people pay ibram kenzie
20 grand a pop to tell their employees
they need to tear down capitalism to
fight racism it's bizarre
it is the sign of a society in decline
it is the sign of a civilization that
hates itself so much it won't even stand
up for its fundamental principles
including the principles of the
declaration of independence and that's
the real danger
to the country okay we'll be back later
today with two additional
hours of content otherwise we'll see you
here tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina hair and makeup is
by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
while democrats exploit the death of
ruth bader ginsburg the late justice
sends a message on her final wishes from
beyond the grave
then rioters burn down more of our
politics out of love and compassion
and blm deletes its beliefs check it out
on the michael knowles show